وصل رئيس الاوكراني بدومير زيلين واشنطن
في اول زياره خارجه بلاده منذ اندلاع
الحرب قبل 300 يوم ومن الملتقى بانيلتقي
رئيس الامريكي جو بيدن كما سيلقي خطابا
امام الكونغرس وقال جيلنسكي قبيله مغادرته
انه ذاهب للولايات المتحده لبحث التعاون
بين البلدين وتعزيز القدرات الدفاعيه
للجيش الاوكراني
وصول موكب الرئيس الاوكراني
الى البيت الابيض اذا هذه الصور مباشره
بوصول الرئيس الاوكراني في الدنيا
فقد كشف وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلين كنان حزمه الجديده من المساعدات
الامريكيه لاوكرانيا تشمل لاول مره نظام
باتريات للدفاع الجوي القادر على اسقاط
صواريخ كروز وصواريخ البالستيه القصيره
المدى وغيرها اذا نتحدث هنا عن هذه
المساعدات التي تاتي بالتزامن مع هذه
الزياره للرئيس الاوكراني بدوير زينكي
للولايات المتحده والذي يصل في هذه
اللحظات الى البيت الابيض الكريم اللي كان
قد حذر تسليم اسلحه امريكيه جديده الى
اوكرانيا سيؤدي الى تفاقم الصراع ولا يبشر
بالخير